This is very interesting. We now have a full month
into Joe Biden's presidency, a full month out of
Donald Trump's presidency. There's a new Economist
YouGov poll that looked at favorability versus on
favorability for a number of the most well-known
American political figures. And the key takeaway
is that Bernie Sanders and Joe Biden, by almost
exactly the same degrees, are the most relatively
well-liked national elected officials in the
United States. The poll was released yesterday.
It found that 49 percent of Americans have a very
or somewhat favorable view of Bernie Sanders,
while Joe Biden has a 50 percent mostly
or somewhat favorable view when you look
at the unfavorable. So Bernie's 49 favorable,
39 unfavorable. Joe Biden, on the other hand,
is 50 favorable, 42 unfavorable. These are
both essentially within the margin of error.
And they tell us that right now in the United
States, the most I mean, I don't think popular
is the wrong word to use the most popular or the
most well-liked net favorable elected officials
are the current president, Joe Biden, as well
as Senator Bernie Sanders, the furthest left
member of the United States Senate. Now, for
a comparison, Vice President Kamala Harris
has a slightly smaller net favorability. So net
favorability is favorability minus unfavorable at
Bernie at 49, 39 is at plus 10. Biden at 50, 42 is
at plus eight and Kamala Harris at 48. Favorable,
43 unfavorable is at plus five. Someone like
Alexandria Castillo Cortez also polled at plus
one favorability. And that's maybe not surprising.
AOC very well liked among those that like her,
very much disliked among those
that dislike her, Mitch McConnell,
one of the least liked politicians in the
country. Net favorability for McConnell
was minus forty eight, with only 17 percent
of the country viewing McConnell favorably.
Sixty five percent viewing him unfavorably.
Joe Manchin minus eleven. Joe Manchin,
the most conservative member of Senate Democrats
among the Democratic members of the Senate, the
most conservative. And these are very interesting
numbers for a few different reasons. When Donald
Trump was president of the United States, he
never reached 50 percent approval. Now, approval,
remember, is different than favorability.
Trump never reached 50 percent approval and
left office with the lowest approval rating in
the history of the polling era for any president.
Joe Biden came in and in different
polls, had the highest initial approval
of any president in the last twenty eight years.
Joe Biden with initial approval. One poll had him
at fifty eight percent, another had him at sixty
three percent. Really, really high numbers. And
the fact that when it comes to favorability,
we are also seeing Joe Biden be one of the most
well-liked American politicians, tells us
that these numbers, these one off numbers,
63 percent approval, 69 percent approval on
handling of covid, 80 percent support for his
mask. Again, to call it a mandate is a bit much,
but federal mandate plus national recommendation,
these are not flukes and these are the entire
package of numbers makes a lot of sense. Now,
the question we have to get to is, so what? What
is Joe Biden now going to do? I've been talking
now for we're into week five uncovered relief
and the belief is that we are getting closer
to covid relief that Joe Biden overpromised
by saying checks would go out right away.
Yeah, probably. But it's time to just do it.
Joe Biden has the highest initial approval
and one of the highest favorability right
now of any American politician. The country
mostly wants the covid relief bill. What are we
waiting for here, given that Republicans have
made it clear from the beginning their goal is
only to obstruct, they proposed instead of a one
point nine dollars billion package, this pathetic
tiny package, 600 billion, cutting a whole bunch
of the key elements of the bill out. What are we
waiting for? Joe Biden has the approval rating.
Joe Biden has the favorability. Joe Biden has
the American people's view on covid relief on
his side. What are we waiting for at this point?
It's time to do it. And I am where I think we're
just a couple of days, maybe even one day from the
next Gallup tracking poll with Biden's approval.
I'm curious to see where it is, but I don't know
of any reason to wait any longer for just passing
covid relief via budget reconciliation. Let every
Republican vote against it. If that's what they
want to do. I don't think they will because they
know it's popular with their own constituents.